peter thiel is one of the most legendary
investors in silicon valley
i build companies and i support people
who are building new things from social
networks to rocket ships
he's helped build paypal facebook and
palantir into massive multi-billion
dollar companies and now
he has his sights set on space
manufacturing and i'm not talking about
making rockets here on earth when i say
space manufacturing
i actually mean producing physical goods
in low earth orbit and then bringing
them back down to earth
if all that sounds a little crazy don't
worry it was completely new to me when i
started working on this video but i'm
going to take you through the
fascinating history of space
manufacturing and then work through
exactly how teal and his team are
planning to make this a reality when
you're a multi-billionaire like teal
you don't need to get your hands dirty
with founding a company to attack an
interesting problem anymore teel has
created a platform for building and
scaling the most promising business
ideas with founders fund his
six billion dollar investment firm and
founders fund
isn't like most venture capital shops
the majority of vcs focus on meeting
entrepreneurs that are running existing
businesses
and then giving them money to help grow
what's already working they usually take
a board seat and help set the high level
strategy
but it doesn't go much deeper than that
and founders fund does do
a lot of deals that look exactly like
that but recently
they've been going a level deeper and
actually co-founding companies alongside
entrepreneurs
they did this with the defense
technology company onderil where trey
stevens who's a partner at founders fund
stepped up to co-found the company
alongside palmer lucky
this model is typically called an
incubation or
a venture studio company and there have
been some massive successes
the cloud storage company snowflake was
started this way by sutter hill ventures
and is now worth 80 billion dollars and
this
is the model that teal and founders fund
are using to make space manufacturing a
reality
at the center of this project is delia
asperhoff he's vc at founders fund and a
co-founder of varda space industries
he'd been tracking the trends in the
aerospace industry for years
and assembled a team to build this new
company the name varda is a tolkien
reference
like the other founders fund incubations
palantir and andarel
deleon has basically been speed running
silicon valley for the past eight years
his resume has it all ted talk check mit
dropout
check y combinator founder check startup
investor
check and now he's basically speed
running the company building process
varda raised a 9 million seed round back
in december of 2020 and they just closed
a 42 million
series a in july of 2021. that's a
pretty insane amount of money to raise
so quickly but delian has a unique
strategy for capturing this new market
that completely justifies a more
aggressive fundraising timeline
the typical path in silicon valley used
to be work for a big company for 10
years
then work for a startup for the next 10
and then maybe become as vc in your 40s
but delian is moving ridiculously
quickly which will be a big
theme throughout this story in fact he's
so obsessed with speed
that he counts the exact number of days
since varda was founded this is the best
way to institute an ethos because at the
end of the day the thing that is always
difficult
about startups is early on it's easy to
move super fast when you're like six
people in a room you all can communicate
really easy et cetera once you become
600 all of a sudden just decisions start
to slow down things start to slow down
it's easy to look at delia's insane
level of energy and think that he might
be getting ahead of himself on this
whole
manufacturing stuff in space thing but
he's been watching the industry closely
for years
and space manufacturing actually dates
back to the 60s
our great system will be judged uh by
how we do in the field of space
even though america won the space race
and landed a man on the moon on july
20th 1969 it was the russians who were
technically the first to manufacture
something in space
during the soyuz 6 mission russian
cosmonauts welded aluminum
titanium and stainless steel together
using a hardware unit called vulcan
four years later the united states
launched skylab
a fully functional space station
equipped with a materials processing
facility that could grow crystals
process alloys and weld metals using an
electron beam
all told nasa astronauts spent 32 man
hours manufacturing stuff in space
during that mission and they made some
pretty significant contributions that
would be rolled into future missions
ten years after the sky lab launch nasa
began
using the space lab facility space lab
was a module that was carried aboard the
space shuttle
26 different times and served as a short
duration research platform
it wouldn't stay in space but while it
was up there it accomplished some pretty
incredible things
space lab was an extremely large program
and could be reconfigured for each
mission
which led to an extremely high
throughput of experimentation
for example in just one mission nasa
performed
73 separate experiments in material
science
astrophysics and atmospheric research
here's a picture of a mercuric iodide
crystal that was grown on space lab 3.
pretty incredible fast forward to today
and essentially all space manufacturing
takes place on the international space
station
most of the products that are made in
space are designed to stay in space
and this makes sense giving astronauts
the ability to fabricate parts quickly
while aboard the space station
speeds up research and development and
there's even a plan to 3d print
food on the station eventually but
delian has a completely different vision
for varda the more let's say you know
commercial reason to start the company
is that there's actually a whole wide
aware array of products that could
significantly improve quality of life
for people here on earth that can only
manufacture it in microgravity
delion wants to bring everything that
varda makes in space
back down to earth if that sounds
insanely expensive
that's because it is at least for now
delhian's entire plan with varda is to
position the company to take advantage
of the exponentially decreasing cost of
space travel
see when it comes to making computer
chips we've been blessed by
exponentially decreasing costs for
decades now
the number of transistors in a dense
integrated circuit essentially doubles
every two years
this is called moore's law and it
explains why computers have been getting
smaller
faster and cheaper so consistently
something similar is happening with
space travel right now
when the space shuttle was in operation
launching a single kilogram into space
cost 54 000 on average spacex has been
able to reduce that cost
to just under 3 000 using their falcon 9
rocket
and it's only getting cheaper every year
spacex is launching more and more
rockets
and dropping the cost of getting to
space this is critical for dellion's
plan for varda
and the main reason why he couldn't
pursue this idea sooner elon plans to
bring the cost per kilo down to just
10 dollars with starship and while
that's certainly an ambitious target
if he can even get close the economics
of space manufacturing will start to
make a lot of sense
but you're probably asking yourself what
would you even make in space
we seem to be doing fine here on earth
so what could possibly be worth all this
effort well
there are a few good examples the first
is human organs
growing a replacement heart or kidney in
space might sound a little weird to some
people but if you're one
of the 100 000 people waiting for an
organ transplant
i'm pretty sure you won't care where it
came from as long as it works
and there's a lot of evidence suggesting
that growing organs in microgravity
yields remarkable results since the
cells don't collapse under their own
weight in space
semiconductor film could also benefit
from low earth orbit production with
some studies estimating that
quality could increase by ten thousand
percent that's a huge step
up from what's possible on earth but
that's because semiconductor film
not only benefits from the microgravity
environment but also from the complete
lack of dust in space
tiny dust particles routinely reduce the
effectiveness of semiconductors here on
earth but that's not a problem
1000 miles up the third opportunity is
fiber optic cables which powers the
entire global internet there is a
special type of fiber optic cable
made from fluoride glass called zb land
that could have as little as 1 10
the signal loss of traditional optical
fiber the problem is that these zb lan
fibers
are extremely difficult to make here on
earth and again it all comes down to
gravity
as the molten glass is stretched into
ultra-thin fibers
tiny crystals tend to form which can
weaken signals
when you're up in space the microgravity
environment suppresses the formation of
these crystals
so the resulting cables can carry more
data over longer distances
human tissue growth has been tested on
the iss but it's impossible to even try
fiber optic production in space
currently for example in a lot of fiber
optics there's a toxic chemical that you
want to coat the fiber optic with that
protects it at the end of the process no
way is nasa going to let you put that
toxic chemical in the iss if that thing
gets out like you're potentially killing
astronauts
but varda's space factories will be
completely autonomous everything varda
launches into space will be completely
self-contained
meaning they can work on any
manufacturing problem without risking
human lives
okay so we've established that what
vardas trying to do is only possible
because scientists have been testing
space manufacturing for decades
and spacex has dropped the cost of
rocket launches so dramatically
but here's where the technology gets
really interesting see
varda won't be building rockets only
payloads that sit on top of spacex
rockets
but they still have to solve a few key
problems once
everything is actually up there so delia
and his team are focusing on building
three different systems
the first is the actual factory this
needs to be small enough
and light enough to fit on a rocket
while still holding all of the raw
materials for whatever they are going to
make on that trip but you can't just
shoot a box into space and hope that it
stays up there and then lands where you
can find it
so they are also building a satellite to
accompany the factory in space
and serve as command and control module
lastly
once the product is actually finished
you have to get it back down to
earth and that's no easy task
atmospheric re-entry
is an extremely risky maneuver and by
far the hardest part of getting
anything from space home safely we have
regulated by the faa because like we're
re-entering over airspace if we like
miss
you know the atmosphere even literally
by like three or four seconds you're
talking about like rather than like
landing in the united states you're like
accidentally like landing in like europe
this really illustrates how aggressive
dellien's plan is for varda
there are a few other companies that are
working on space manufacturing currently
but they mostly focus on developing the
factory exclusively
and then partner with nasa to get
everything to the space station and back
the scale of the re-entry problem really
can't be understated in order to stay in
orbit
anything in space needs to be traveling
incredibly fast a commercial airliner
typically flies at around
500 miles per hour but the international
space station is traveling at 17
000 miles per hour
the deceleration that occurs during
re-entry is extremely powerful
and anything varda makes in space will
have to be able to make it through
re-entry
without getting damaged in the process
this part of the equation is so critical
to varda's success
that delia even recruited a ceo with
experience specifically in
re-entry but i realized that for the ceo
position i wanted somebody that sort of
has been at spacex
specifically on dragon in particular
because we have a sort of re-entry
problem that we're trying to solve and
you know the dragon is basically the
only
commercial reentry vehicle that's ever
been built varda is clearly a moonshot
type of company
but delian is placing his bats very
carefully spacex is top-notch in terms
of rockets
so no need to re-engineer things there
but no one has figured out how to solve
re-entry at the industrial scale varda
is aiming for
not even nasa nasa is an amazing
organization
but their budget is just 24 billion
dollars per year
for comparison walmart spends that much
money
every three weeks while partnering with
government research teams can work in
some cases
it's not ideal for scaling an entirely
new industry
for varda to be truly successful they
need to be launching dozens of factories
to space every month
with varda the initial product that
we're going after if we were to
eventually satisfy the entire market
that we're going after
we would have multiple of our re-entry
capsules coming down per day and we
would be buying a spacex
rocket every other day okay so clearly
varda has ambitious
goals but exactly how big of a market is
space manufacturing anyway
well it's currently a rounding error but
the global space industry is valued at
around 420 billion dollars
and that's growing really rapidly just
last year investors poured nearly 10
billion dollars into space companies
each with slightly different approaches
companies like hadrian and relativity
are developing products on earth that
are meant for space
and a company called made in space is
you guessed it
making things in space but everything
made in space produces
is meant to stay in space not come back
down to earth
that's where varda is unique when it
comes to the growth of the space
industry we're seeing steady progress
start to compound in all sorts of key
metrics
the cost of launching a satellite is
falling dramatically
the time between launches is getting
shorter and shorter
and even the number of humans who have
been to space is
increasing faster than ever before when
jeff bezos returned to earth after his
trip
on blue origin's new shepard rocket he
had some really poignant words about the
importance of space manufacturing
we need to take all heavy industry all
polluting industry
and move it into space and keep earth as
this beautiful gem of a planet that it
is
now that's going to take decades and
decades to achieve but you have to start
and big things start with small steps
so can space manufacturing become a
seven trillion dollar
industry that number is certainly a bit
ridiculous but the global manufacturing
industry
does generate well over seven trillion
dollars per year
and sure we're not going to move all of
that to space anytime soon but what
about in 100 years
how about a thousand humanity is going
to become multi-planetary
probably within our lifetime and when we
begin seriously expanding our solar
footprint
we're gonna have options as to where we
choose to build specific things
we'll be able to put certain things on
earth other things on mars and we'll
have plenty of space in between
pun very much intended some people find
it difficult to get excited about things
that will take
years if not decades to bear fruit but i
for one am not one of those people
big things have small beginnings and
varda is clearly the first
small step in an incredible direction if
you want to chat about space
manufacturing
just leave me a comment below or dm me
on twitter and please check out this
recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it